tout je suis inquiet larpin système
ariane droit retenez bien ce nom c'est
la nouvelle révélation radio-canada dans
la catégorie chanson
[Musique]
j'aime
rien
j'étais tellement content quand j'ai
appris que c'était toi la révélation est
du canada parce que tu es une des
artistes que j'ai le plus écouté de
l'année 2021
c'est un opt vais lancer dans des
circonstances particulières oui j'ai
lancé le pays le 6 mars donc c'est
vraiment là une semaine de la tombe et
la pandémie avant que tout s'écroule et
que c'était un drôle de timing mais
bizarrement je considère quand même que
j'ai été chanceuse c'est que l'artiste
de 24 ans a eu une année bien chargée
le participer au concours destination
chanson fleuve au festival de la chanson
de petite vallée
[Musique]
au festival international de la chanson
de granby et aussi aux francouvertes
[Musique]
du futile du mascara
le talent d'ariane roy a été remarquée
et saluée et c'est maintenant au tour de
radio-canada de soutenir sa carrière un
an sur toutes ses plateformes d ir
ariane leroy nouvelles révélations
chanson canada les révélations
radio-canada existe depuis 2008
une soixantaine d'artistes ont reçu cet
honneur qui est pas les moindres émile
bilodeau hubbard le noir les coeurs des
pirates ont reçu ce coup de pouce en
début de carrière
félicitations sûr que quand radio-canada
ça m'a vraiment aidé c'est une grosse
affaire à l'époque le pis elle est
encore aujourd'hui la donne le goût de
d'être à la hauteur aussi fait idiot qui
le jass heures je peux pas à l'arrivée à
moitié il faut que ça soit salée pour
faire travailler les autres lauréats de
la cuvée 2021 son jackson sanaa dans la
catégorie musique métissée le quatuor
mené par julien fillion en jazz la
rappeuse calamine et la violoniste
passionnés de musique ancienne marie
nadeau tremblay des révélations à
découvrir pour l'amour de la musique ici
n'est dit alexandre chartier adjé canada
montréal
[Musique]